heraf zu starren der staat uns doch an
sie mal kommen sie vorbei wir machen
eine kleine party der film verräter wie
wir basiert auf dem gleichnamigen roman
von john le carré umgesetzt von
regisseurin designer wild mit ewan
mcgregor in den hauptrollen nummer eins
der geldwäscher in der russischen mafia
ist das alles was sie haben berger
spielt ein professor für politik der
ganz zufällig in eine globale in
tripolis übergeben einfach und damit hat
es sich er sagte seine kinder würden
sonst getötet
auf einer party ist in der nähe des
buchhalters der russischen mafia den
spiel stellen skarsgard mit viel liebe
am kulturellen klischee und das gilt für
den ganzen film alle entsprechend
perfekt ihrem typus noch nie hatten
informanten so weit oben in russland
organisierten verbrechen britische
politiker anwälte und banker von russen
hier in london rekrutiert was will er
asyl für sich und seine familie
der professor ist der feingliedrige
intellektuelle der müssen und der
bessere lebe man kann ja nicht mitmachen
doch es fällt schwer ewan mcgregor den
literaturwissenschaftler abzukaufen wegs
im laufe des films entwickelt er sich
eher zu einem laien erkennen
die figuren sind in verräter wie wir nur
funktionsträger in erster linie verlässt
regisseurin auf die lebendigkeit gas gab
der film schafft es nicht konkret zu
werden
es geht um eine finanzielle intrige doch
die ist nur in den allergrößten zügen
nachzuvollziehen sie das auto am ende
läuft alles auf eine liste mit
nummernkonten hinaus das hätte man
genauer beleuchten sollen
denn es gibt einen bedarf nach film die
komplexe vorgänge und systeme erklären
in verräter wie wir ist der professor
von den geldströmen in london in
vielerlei hinsicht betroffen
es ändert sich die farbe ist blutgeld
dort film ist blind für solche
zusammenhänge halten sie versteckt
schlussendlich läuft alles auf einen
simplen männerfreundschaft hinaus so
susanna white hat einen film gemacht der
sich im fiktionalen viel zu gemütlichen
jahr lang verraten